[Music]
for us Gruyère and important
in our culture
it also represents a part of Switzerland
if we want there are the
chocolate mountains there is cheese and then
Gruyère is part of it
[Music]
genesys
my name is alexandre deserve I'm a
farmer who makes
alpine gruyère
[Music]
vernal page only happened from May to
October while the
cows are on time in the mountains and
it's  is the difference with the
normal Gruyère which is made for it all year round
the grass that we have among other things
on our mountains and rich in flora
and suddenly the cows choose it what
they want to eat I think of a
large part of
cheese is also important for quality my family has been
producing alpine grills for
five generations now so it was
my father who taught me how to make
alpine greer
he made it in a
traditional way so everything is done without
the pipes  be but i think that
i  oue a role in the taste of the cheese
also
the process of making Gruyère
d'alpage it starts there 5am in the
morning we go get the cows
then we do the milking the milk goes
directly into the boiler
[Music]
then into  the offset is to make
the grains of the cheese
then it is heated and at 56 degrees in
the fate for the pressing
after the pressing it is put in a bath
of salts for 24 hours
to then be brought to the cades
in the refining  cheese lasts about
six months but after that you can live with
cheese for up to two years
[Music]
there are different ways to eat
Gruyère but where I am, the best
way I find is with a good
piece of Gruyère with  a piece of
bread is where you feel the
taste of cheese the best
the continuation of this tradition
it is important because my family has been doing it for years
and I think it is
beautiful to perpetuate the tradition
[Music]